aujourd'hui les sites internet proposent
une multitude de stage de survie
loin d'être un phénomène récent ce
concept s'est développée dès les années
80 et hier comme aujourd'hui même combat
ne pas mourir de faim une source de
tension pour ces stagiaires affamés en
1986 le ravitaillement ne vient pas et
s'il ne vient jamais vous croyez qu
actuellement vous allez vous nourrir de
quatre frères médiévaux ni faire quoi
le stage de survie de khouribga quasi
venu faire le stage de survie se repérer
construit un abri fait un feu ok mais
comment se remplir l'estomac
il faut beaucoup marché et beaucoup cru
mais attention tout n'est pas comestible
il faut repérer les bonnes plantes il y
en a partout à portée de main mais
lesquels choisir
accompagnés d'un moniteur 1984 ces
stagiaires découvrent et les attraits du
caprice à l'allié du stagiaire en 1989
comme aujourd'hui c'était lortie au menu
de ces ados soupe de neige fondue ortyl
puissants ni et c'est bon phaneuf à
sopot saingou quand on l'a fait moi j'ai
plein de ressources
nos ados vont pourtant trouver une
solution plus rassasiante avec la pêche
à la truite et à mains nues
démonstration j'aime quand même et si
vous préférez une bonne viande
vous pouvez également vous offrir
quelques extras protéique plutôt
insolite
c'est les races et les souris qui
peuvent facilement souvent je mangeais
des rats et des souris dans sa non ok
pas de rats mais que devient vite un bon
civet de lapin
oui mais pour cela il va falloir tuer
attention âmes sensibles s'abstenir
un dernier espace vous l'aurez compris
adopté le régime robinson n'est pas si
simple
mais n'ayez crainte en stage on ne vous
laissera jamais mourir de faim
[Musique]